well I wrote a whole chapter in my book
alex's adventures numberland about pi
because it's kind of the most famous
number in maths it's this is a celebrity
number
pi is the simplest possible ratio of the
simplest possible shape so the simplest
possible shape being a circle really and
pi is the ratio of all the way around it
to all the way across it its
circumference to its diameter and the
Babylonians first thought it was about
three
in fact they wrote it down as three what
is interesting is that it's the simplest
possible ratios of the simplest possible
shape but it's the most complicated kind
of ugly number it doesn't slice neatly
it's what's called an irrational number
which means that if you were to express
it as a decimal the decimals just go on
forever without ever repeating and
people have been fascinated by this idea
that something so simple something so
basic it sort of lets you into this mess
and madness and chaos so I would like if
with your permission to talk about the
work that was done by Archimedes which
has been discovered and he did it in the
following way so there was this
brilliant kind of narrative of human
expedition like kind of trying to get to
the moon and then to get to the next
planet of trying to find more and more
digits
he took a unit circle so I got to make a
unit circle on here and draw it out in
green so that you can see that's a
simple circle lovely circle I know it's
I couldn't have drawn it better freehand
also it was one of the first numbers to
gain its own symbol because you can't
keep on writing 3.1415 all the time and
once it gained the you know pi probably
short for periphery this symbol it just
became quite iconic
now I'm going to draw inside a triangle
and I'll try and make this have equal
sign so we call it an equilateral
triangle so just say you were an ancient
Egyptian we'll make something pi is
going to come up because you're going to
be need to calculating the size of you
know of rims and spokes and things like
that now if I were to walk around this
path or
all the way all the way around that is a
longer path for me to walk than the path
that goes straight in a straight line
between these points between these
points and between these points so you
can see this perimeter is bigger than
that though then he went to the next
stage and put another little triangle in
here another one there and another one
there and you get a hexagon that just
mean six equal sides and this is getting
closer in length to this perimeter and
then he went to the next stage to make
something with twelve sides so you end
up with a 12 sided figure then he did 24
the nearly 48 and he did 96 and this
length is still less than the radius of
the circle because when you go in a
straight line it's quicker than going on
a curved line and he got out pi is which
is the circumference is 2 pi times the
radius this pi he gets out is 3 plus 10
over 71 that's a bound that pi has got
to be greater than this because this
curved surface is greater than this
number when you have a ninety six sided
regular figure so that wasn't the end of
the story because that doesn't give you
the answer he then considered a triangle
that goes outside with three equal sides
now clearly this is much longer you go
much further going along this path so
this is going to give a greater bound
than pi and then he filled it in with
lines and with lines and now you've got
a hexagon that goes around this circle
and then he filled it in with more and
he carried on like this till the cows
come home he went all the way up to
ninety six sided figures again and that
gave him the other bound which is pi is
less than three plus 10 over 70 and
using that method
Archimedes sort of up the ante and
closer and that was for I think 1,000
years was basically how people estimated
pie and so he got to limits for this and
worked out from that that pie is about
three point one four one to the next
great jump in understanding how to
calculate pi required the era in the
Enlightenment and the invention of
calculus so he wouldn't slightly
precalculus the idea of the infinite
series the simplest infinite series for
Pi is PI over four is equal to one minus
1/3 plus 1/5 minus the seventh plus 1/9
etc etc etc so what you need to do is
you just need to add as many of the
terms on as possible which are kind of
zigzagging and sort of honing in on Pi
and the more you do the closer you'll
get PI people do it on computers and get
it to hundreds of places of decimals or
more I have no idea how accurately this
is this is the realm of the super geek
the better the computers got and what
did you say one and now I think three or
seven trillion digits and PI's been the
last ones deciders remember the digits
in PI it's just as difficult or just as
easy it was just exactly the same as the
digits and square root of 2 square root
of 3 Phi e but no one wants to remit
memorize those ones they want to
memorize PI I wouldn't be doing my job
properly if I didn't ask you how many
digits you can remember pi two five
three point one four five nine then
maybe is a two after that yeah I'm hey
my memories not you know I don't like to
spend my spare time memorizing pi I got
3.14159 and I've got a mnemonic beauty
of pi is fascinating but just memorizing
things is not my bag how I like to drink
alcoholic of course
after two heavy lectures involving
quantum mechanics at first people with
sort of diskens
dirted by the fact that pi the numbers
and pi the digits never repeat how has
three letters I has 13.1 like four to
3.14 to drink five alcoholic nine but
actually this fact they don't repeat is
actually what's fascinating of to and
then we're getting where I don't know to
six course after five the heavy lectures
the pattern they are so devoid of any
pattern that actually digits in PI if
taken as random numbers are the most
random numbers that we know of really
they pass whether we every test for
randomness with it with flying colors
after five the three heavy five lectures
I can't count eight involving quantum
mechanics and you can get even longer
ones and these these are ways of
remembering if you can remember the
phrase but of course I can't remember
the phrase I prefer to remember the
number what you had during the 1970s and
80s was a as an arms race between
America and Japan where you know the two
great tech nations developing their
supercomputers and really no one really
cares what digit is the two bit of digit
in pi is but you want to do it because
it shows how strong your computer is
they're not interested in the digits in
PI because it's going to be any use in
terms of doing any calculations of a
circles because just say you know you're
a high-precision wheel design or
something
Oh even if you need doing something
forever like a spaceship 10 PI to ten
decimal places that's probably more than
enough you're just never going to need
that much but now we have it to several
trillion decimal places so physicist
there's an engineering approach that if
you've got it on your calculator to
enough so different figures you really
don't care because most of the time when
we're working in physics you work to two
or three significant figures it's good
for testing computers and it's also a
fantastic to have this
of beautifully random numbers it's kind
of perfect chaos